[Music]
hello you're watching the press preview
it's a first look at what is on the
front pages it's time to check out the
headlines tonight with the daily mails
consultant editor andrew pearce and the
daily mirrors associate editor kevin
mcguire they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight look at that
bunting fantastic bunting badges as well
speaking to them in a moment first of
all let's check out the front pages for
you starting with the eye the eye
heralds the queen's platinum jubilee
with a simple headline 70 knot out
the telegraph carries a passage from her
majesty's special message to mark the
occasion in which she says we look to
the future with confidence
and enthusiasm
and the sun is also full of praise for
the queen
again using that new photo
likewise the express which proclaims a
grateful nation salutes you mom
now on the political front the guardian
hears that boris johnson has been told
that his own efforts to change the
ministerial code in a possible attempt
to avoid blame for partygate risk
undermining public trust
the financial times quotes jp morgan
chase's chief executive jamie dimon
warning investors that an economic
hurricane is on the way
and in the midst of the travel chaos
across the country the star has an image
of a pilot who resorted to loading his
own aircraft with baggage
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen join the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
andrew pearce and kevin maguire lovely
to see you both and um good to see you
put some decorations up as well andrew
kevin where's your where's your union
flag
oh well i've got my uh jubilee mug it's
uh platinum liz uh 70 years on benefits
just for a little bit of balance
platinum liz love it great well we'll
talk about the jubilee in a moment but
uh first of all let's talk about the uh
the breaking news in the last couple of
hours uh regarding johnny depp and amber
heard all the papers just about managing
to squeeze it in before the first
editions go to press um uh andrew why
don't you kick things off front page of
the guardian
quoting amber heard statement after that
verdict was delivered she says i'm
heartbroken
well you know this um she shouldn't have
written the article in the first place
should she she wrote an article in the
washington post first person talking
about um being a victim of domestic
abuse it was clearly aimed at her
husband and the jury found unanimously
again and again and again that it was a
vindictive attempt to destroy him it's
had a profound effect on his career
already it's most i think some estimates
that he's correct he's lost 40 million
dollars already he's been written out of
the harry potter follow-up uh uh and
also the great johnny depp the great um
pirates of the caribbean so there's no
point in having pirates of the caribbean
without having johnny depp look we all
both characters in this trial came out
as deeply flawed but she looked i i mean
i was talking to my girlfriends about
this we all thought she was lying uh
they were both flawed characters nobody
really wins in all of this but i've got
to say i'm pleased he's the victor
although uh he probably needs to take
some time now to and rather clever of
him what's he doing he's performing he
was in the albert hall the other night
uh and he's in newcastle tonight she was
in the court cake in the courtroom very
dramatic very emotional but you have to
say she's in big trouble now because
she's going to have to find millions and
millions of pounds in damages and costs
and she was never an earner in the
league of johnny depp in the first place
yeah i mean kevin it has been so public
and so graphic hasn't it i think i think
it's been many many years before we've
been give since we've been given a sort
of an insight into a hollywood such a
dysfunctional hollywood relationship he
may have won the case but do you think
his career can recover
well i suppose hollywood is all about
money and it's whether he can you know
get bottoms on seats and people will pay
to go see his films and that's what the
uh the big movie companies will be
thinking but it was it was a horror show
it was free for us
uh it's not turned out to be free for
amber heard who lost 15 million to 2
million because she had that one small
victory but the
yeah it's a position where she wins in
london in the high court he loses he
wins in virginia she loses but uh i
think andrew is right they both lost in
a way because we saw that both have a
rather unpleasant sides to their to
their character and uh boards behaved
incredibly badly in in the past
i hope she recovers uh i hope she can
move on i hope she gets movie parts uh
certainly she was getting a hell of a
lot of abuse but of course he's a he's a
far bigger figure as andrew said and
then you always have an element of
misogyny too in the abuse you see online
it's it's it's there in whatever walk of
life you are are in but
what a terrible terrible case yeah it
was just all yeah i followed it but it
was and you you kind of oh but you know
you're looking into two people's souls
uh and you would say neither yeah nice
yeah and andrew just just very quickly
i'm just going to ask you about the
cameras because the cameras are
fascinating aren't they as you know
cameras not really allowed in courts uh
on uh uh uh
in the majority of time here in the uk
but out there the judge made the
decision that cameras would be allowed
that does mean doesn't it every second
is poured over and of course re-edited
now by members of the public and shoved
onto instagram tick tock or twitter
all over the internet and that's what
made it so compelling because um you
could read it in the papers and it was
fascinating but then you could watch it
on tv you could watch their actions
how composed she appeared to be all the
sobbing and weeping and wailing in the
witness box by her how cool he looked
but then you also thought god he used to
be a bit of a god in terms of looks he
put on weight weird hair weird clothes
and then the extraordinary performance
by kate moss who never gives interviews
never give interviews and then i we saw
her by video link from her home and i
thought i don't think i've ever heard
kate moss's voice before that's why the
whole case was so surreal so absolutely
fascinating and of course he did wheel
out lots of people to support him to say
there was never any suggestion of abuse
by him including his former wife uh and
um and he seemed to have all the uh the
big guys on his side
okay let's talk about something uh much
more uh pleasant shall we um front page
of the telegraph it's a photograph in
many of the papers this rather lovely uh
new photograph of the queen in what is
quite a relaxed pose she's sitting in a
window seat at windsor castle and as the
telegraph
says kevin uh she's saying that we look
to the future with confidence and
enthusiasm and over the next few days i
think we are going to get a sense aren't
we about
how the queen wants the monarchy to look
going forward she's going to very subtly
set out her stall i think for the future
of the royal family
yeah i think it's a rather nice
photograph but i think you know the
you know it's a very pleasant picture of
a granny grey grandmother um and i think
much better uh pictured that way
portrayed that way rather than in
uniforms and sasha's and and
whatever but um no republicans like me
are just gonna have to suck it up over
this long uh uh bank holiday uh weekend
mark in her 70th uh yeah uh
of a horrific privilege um i'm not sure
actually it's the right tone to talk
about uh you know the future in the way
she has confidence and enthusiasm in the
middle of a cost of living crisis when
people are worried about nine percent
inflation and declining living standards
uh yeah what potentially
extend from from all those pressures
because of the the sovereign grant 80
million plus and she's one of the
richest women in the country if not the
world so i i do i do you know i can see
why a lot of people want to
want to bend the knee and bow and curtsy
but i'm just not sure that is the tone
she should take yeah front page of the
sun uh don't you just love er um and
again that photograph um kevin um i mean
we are going to enjoy the next four days
or many of us are going to are going to
enjoy it and celebrate but but i think
there is also
i think the mail andrews paper had 12
million people were going to go to
lunches street parties and so on that
does mean actually in a country of 67
million 55 million don't which is uh
just more than four and five i think a
little perspective is there but now i
hope it's i hope it's sunny for
everybody who wants to celebrate and
have a party and have a good time and uh
and have a knees up and any old excuse a
couple of my neighbors have uh i've got
bunting up
i've offered to go around and find out
who did it if they're regular objects
and it wasn't them but uh no it's
yeah well at the site at the same time
we can all get a little bit or some
people can get a bit too carried away
look at look there you are
your neighbor
kevin kevin he is completely graceless
isn't he and tone death this is a
remarkable milestone in the life of
anybody we're never going to get a
platinum jubilee again it will be
probably decades before there's another
jubilee for a british monarch she's done
70 years when she was 21 she pledged a
life of service and that's exactly what
she's given she's given her heart to
this job she's given her country to this
job i wouldn't have wanted that job for
all the tea in china she doesn't go on
exotic or foreign holidays or travel the
world in private jets she works she goes
to scotland in the into balmoral
in the summer
and she's happy with her horses she's a
fantastic example of selflessness and
devotion to duty she looks great in that
photograph and she's quite right to talk
to people about looking forward to a
happy future she's hardly going to say
i'm sorry you're all struggling and
worrying about the cost of living crisis
this is a weekend in which she's talking
about have a good weekend a good bank
holiday weekend and kevin might not like
it but the estimate is one billion
people would be tuning in on tv
worldwide to watch the celebration they
wouldn't do that for the queen of spain
they wouldn't do that for the queen of
uh of um sweden and they certainly
wouldn't do it for clear stamina and the
labor party or a president or president
of the united kingdom no way she's a
living embodiment of british public
pageantry at its best andrew you you
know that is a made-up figure that one
bit
and there's more than 7 billion in the
in the world but anyway it's a made-up
figure my objection isn't to her as a
person or most of them as people might
make an exception with andrew uh after
that 12 million pounds sex uh settlement
case it's it's the actual principle do
not mean it's the idea of a hereditary
institution as head of state and you do
not get to say there's no meritocracy in
it there's no democracy in it there's no
equality in it it's all there to try and
stop change and kind of in a way give a
sheen a glean right
establishment respectability to er
inequality and unfairness
i hope you're not going to fume all over
the bank holiday weekend
have a great time listen listen i want
to move on
we're short of time so i want to move on
and i want to focus on the front of the
guardian uh kevin in fact the the queen
the jubilee is uh pushed into the into
the corner of the front page uh they're
majoring instead on changes uh to the
ethics code tell us about this story
yeah the guardians remembered its uh
republican roots there up at the
top right when i worked for it was had a
campaign to abolish the monarch you
didn't get too far it's going to be said
but look at the fight goes on now the
this is uh
jonathan evans who is the chair of the
committee on in on public life he's a
former mi5 chief so he's no rogue sphere
uh warning that uh boris johnson's
changes to the ministerial code which
means miners
ministers will have to resign for what
are called a minor infringement and
christopher guy government's ethics uh
uh tsar
who
is said to have been thinking of
resigning unless the prime minister
justified uh how we can somehow stay
when he's been fined finally breaking
won't be allowed to launch independent
investigations and according to evans
this is undermining public trust and it
comes as more conservative mps speak out
against boris johnson who could possibly
next week face a confidence vote andrew
just give me a sentence on this and then
we're going to move on
i think it was a completely unnecessary
fight for the prime minister to pick
really uh it just it just it gives off
all the wrong echoes all the wrong
smells i'm sure he's doing it for the
best possible reasons but he looks
pretty bad at a time when um he's a lot
of people thinks he's broken the
minister of code himself okay and andrew
just staying with you um let's have a
look at the holiday chaos uh we've just
got a minute left the map cartoon is
quite good i don't know if we can uh if
we can slide that in it's on the front
of the telegraph uh some people at
check-in um and the the person behind
the check-in counter says is our special
tribute to her majesty we've cancelled
70 flights today which i sort of love um
it's been miserable for so many people
hasn't andrew
absolutely miserable i think the
telegraph's reporting on the front page
the advice now is take a rucksack with
you only if you're going abroad so that
means you're gonna have to buy clothes
and toiletries on holiday to try and
limit the delays these airlines can't
they're absolutely bang out of order
they moaned and complained and whinged
about all the travel restrictions in
britain then while they were lifted they
had no staff they did not enough to get
the staff back they sacked far too many
uh during the lockdown and uh they've
been too slow to recruit them how did
they not know there wouldn't be a huge
surge of people wanting to go abroad as
soon as was practically possible very
disgrace okay uh don't go anywhere
andrew and kevin will of course be
staying with us for the next hour to
discuss tonight's news and tomorrow's
headlines right now as we approach the
celebration